grenzschutz übung am grenzübergang
nickelsdorf in kooperation üben
österreichischen soldaten und
polizeikräfte aus österreich und ungarn
den ernstfall untergrenze maßnahmen ist
jetzt sozusagen auch nachgeholt worden
und der ohne zweifel jetzt verschärfte
auch bedingungen sie auch nicht
vergessen assistenzeinsatz läuft seit
1936 jahren und in den 30 jahren hat sie
die zusammenarbeit zwischen polizei und
bundesheer wir stehen hier schulter an
schulter an der grenze unglaublich
unglaublich verbessert und was man da
noch platz nach oben ist wir haben hier
eine zusammenarbeit die freundschaft und
auf professionalität und das leben wir
tagtäglich an der grenze die soldaten
und polizisten stehen gemeinsam an der
grenze machen einen hervorragenden job
in den unter beweis zu stellen treten
heute dutzende polizei schülerinnen und
polizei schon lagen wir stellen dann die
migranten darunter so dass sie die
einzige verteilungen und auch bundesheer
uns quasi dann unter kontrolle bekommen
wenn wir heute in die grenze sein wollen
also dass das so realitätsnah wie
möglich ist die flüchtlinge kommen in
gruppen um in richtung grenzübergang und
diese personen werden natürlich immer
mehr auf dem grenzübergang und dadurch
wird dann immer wieder verstärken
nachgeholt und diese menschenmengen in
den zaun zu halten
ja es wird speziell in den medien auch
viel diskutiert ob vielleicht eine
zweite flüchtlingswelle kommt und wenn
man zurückdenkt im jahr 2015 was da vor
sich gegangen ist ist man eigentlich gut
darauf sich vorzubereiten falls das noch
einmal passieren sollte dass man darauf
vorbereitet ist zu dieser vorbereitung
gehört auch die enge
zusammenarbeit in der luft
polizeihubschrauber mit wärmebildkamera
melden illegale grenzgänger und ein
blackrock des österreichischen
bundesheeres bringt die
spezialeinsatzkräfte umgehend an ort und
stelle
ich bin dem österreichischen bundesheer
sehr dankbar für die langjährige
kooperation sie wissen wir haben zwei
assistenzeinsätze kontinuierlich laufen
vom österreichischen bundesheer der bibi
direkt zu ziehen einerseits an der
grenze hier von österreich zu ungarn und
gleichzeitig an der grenze von
österreich richtung slowenien hier sind
ca 850 soldaten in der verstärkung für
die österreichische polizei eingesetzt
wir können bis zu 2200 soldatinnen und
soldaten weiter anfordern für solche
szenarien bestmöglich vorbereitet zu
sein ist das eine für
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
ist noch etwas anderes von zentraler
bedeutung